[Music]
hi everyone I'm John here today I'm
talking about how at cloud AI were
inspired by customer needs AI has the
potential to change every industry from
transportation to healthcare from retail
to education
however the what's there is a big gap
between what's possible with AI and
what's within reach for our customers
this gap reviews a lack of awareness on
both sides
on one site many traditional companies
lack of understanding of AI which makes
it hard for them to benefit from it
machine learning development is an
extremely concept complex cycle from the
collecting data designing model tuning
model parameters updating the model
evaluating it and iterates the process
every single step would require machine
learning expertise unfortunately of the
world's 21 million developers only one
milling also have data science
backgrounds and thousands of them have
deep learning on machine learning
expertise and on the other side
technologists who are driving the
development of AI lack of understanding
about traditional industries as a result
many problems that could benefit from AI
remains unsolved unsolved a Google cloud
we're trying to bring our customers and
AI experts together on the shared
platform we try to help our customers to
understand a AI and make xscape ability
more accessible through this process we
develop the first-hand understanding of
their world the challenges they are
facing and by combining this with AI
expertise cuckoo we can address their
problems in powerful new ways by
understanding the diverse range of needs
in today's enterprise environment we're
delivering the power of AI in the form
that we hope to meet our customers where
they are
we provide AI technology across a wide
spectrum of solutions on one side for
the most advanced machine learning
experts we provide the most powerful
machine learning tools for them to build
their vision like GPUs tensorflow
cube flow cloud MO engine etc on the
other are the customers who understand
the value of AI but don't have the
expertise to put it in use for them we
offer simple tools that deliver
immediate results like the machine
learning api's and in between we offer a
growing range of solutions that blend
the ease of use us and sophisticated
capabilities such as contact center we
announced yesterday furthermore with
belief in delivering maximum results for
every customer regardless of their
expertise considered cloudy PU for
example the custom chips that
dramatically accelerate machine learning
tasks with minimal amount of code
advanced a user can run their tensorflow
models antabuse and experience an
immediate boost but even novices can
rely on the performance boost from the
latest Google hardware as ap is like
Translate translation API can
automatically leverage TP use behind the
scenes no matter what's your level of
scale we want to ensure you benefit from
our most powerful technology
we call this democratizing AI but
there's much more we can do to make AI
more accessible to explain where our
technologies go in next I'd look like to
share a bit of the history that I've
witnessed in my own career in computer
vision image classification is among the
greatest success stories in our field in
recent years it has been gone through a
lot of the significant the improvement
and now we're thinking about how to GUI
expand the success of image recognition
to other areas but we are facing a lot
of challenges in doing so the first
challenge is data years were expand
we're spent collecting millions of
images to train algorithms to understand
what we see the second is algorithm
development it took hundreds of
researchers decades to refine the
algorithm behind this single goal a big
big part of democratizing AI will be
finding better ways to replicate what
has made image recognition such access
success this is the promise of automo
Otomo makes it possible to customize our
most advanced machine learning models to
your customized and specific use case
all without writing any machine learning
code our first release came earlier this
year in the form of cloud Ultimo vision
which makes it possible to train the
cloud vision API to recognize
entirely new image categories keller
williams reality is using auto MO vision
to bring to market most advanced home
search experience for consumers by
training a custom model to recognize
common elements of furnishing and
architecture customers can automatically
search home listing photos to find their
specific preferred features like granite
countertops or even more general style
like modern and here at next we have
introduced two additional oto mo
features oto mo natural language and oto
mo translation with auto mode natural
language customers can train custom
models to accurately recognize
domain-specific content in their text
for example in one of our customer
Hearst Newspapers there are one of the
world's largest publishers of magazine
and newspapers they have been always
looking for better ways to manage their
content at Hearst a newspaper they try
to look for they are looking forward to
leverage cloud ml Auto M all natural
language to customize domain-specific
text models for their newspaper content
and that has been providing high
accuracy for their needs without writing
any machine learning code
Ultimo translation helps to recognize
jargon and terms specific to your domain
and the result is Pacioretty translation
to capture the context and Newell's
that your customer will expect so
customers all over the world have been
finding ways to improve translation with
Auto Mall for example Nikkei a media
company based in Japan is evaluating
Auto Mall for translating international
news articles by leveraging
automo it meets the customer
customization needs from them and they
have been very impressed by the accuracy
AI is still a very nascent space and we
know that each of you face some unique
challenge we are eager to learn them and
help solve them that will require us to
keep a close conversation with you let's
talk about the problems in your industry
and what are the ideal outcome look like
and let's work together to use the
latest AI technology to make that vision
a reality
thank you now I'd like to welcome Stefan
to the stage to share how we are
partnering with Si P to bring AI and
enterprise software through to the
physical world using Google Cloud
good afternoon everyone my name is
Stefan Elsa I'm product manager and for
Claudia in Europe here at Google cloud
one of our primary objectives is
democratizing AI lowering the barriers
to entry and making it as easy as
possible for customers all over the
world to put this remarkable
capabilities to use they say/i becomes
more accessible other technologies
benefit as well we see an opportunity
here to use the combined power of AI in
the cloud to make automation more
accessible to industry and to businesses
of all sizes to understand how let's
take a look at industry Fairbank new
industry 4.0 and the state of automation
today there's an exciting transformation
underway in the industrial sector
manufacturing operations and the entire
supply chain are being digitized
this is known as industry 4.0 it
involves sensor rising machines and also
the environment industrial sector
companies want to use that sensor data
to drive machine learning in the eye
this promise is to enable new levels of
optimization and learning the ultimate
goal is to make processes that are
currently manually operated be
controlled much more efficiently
automation plays an important part in
this process now historically automation
has been highly customized in silos with
high upfront costs and and and as a
result of that been the lock it it's
also inflexible if you can afford
automation you'll structure your entire
environment around it
today we're seeing exciting trends in
automation collaborative robots like the
ones shown on this slide that are
equipped with modern sensors and open
software layers that are easier to
program these collaborative robots
promise to transform how we do
automation especially in less structured
environment where these robots can work
side by side with humans so how do we
digitize the physical world in a less
structured environments like the
warehouse that you see on this slide
it's easy to capture sensor readings
from big machines but it's much harder
to digitize goods in storage or
containers of course like bins or
pallets or shelves or boxes especially
if human workers are in the same
workspace and manually move these goods
and containers around we believe we can
solve some of these challenges with the
help of collaborative robots and /
harnessing the power of AI intercloud
and we're not the only ones who see this
opportunity let me tell you a little
about our partner sa p sa p is the world
leader in enterprise applications they
manage business processes of large and
medium-sized companies across the world
think orders parts are inventory levels
their rules are in Europe and in the
industrial sector ACB is working with
their customers to gradually transition
workloads from on-premise to the cloud
that combined with their deep industry
expertise makes them a unique and strong
CCP partner industry 4.0 is a huge
opportunity for sa P to optimize not
only business processes but to take this
optimization closer to the physical
world based on for example real-time
awareness of goods pallets of trolleys
in a warehouse sure the feedback loops
combined with readily available
automation will translate into increased
efficiency and agility for ACPs
customers to capture this opportunity
ACB is looking for ways to manage and
orchestrate collaborative robots from
different vendors and to tap into
insights about the physical world for
better optimization the Klaudia
engineering team in Munich in Germany is
working on an open cloud robotics
platform that adds critical
infrastructure for collaborative robots
it builds on matured CCP technologies
and provides from the HTML capabilities
for cloud enabled automation solutions
our cloud robotics platform securely
connects robots with the cloud it
enables distribution of software and
other digital assets to the robots using
kubernetes containers it provides
infrastructure for collecting log data
for uploading it monitoring it and
creating dashboards using stackdriver
it also provides infrastructure for
sensor data collection aggregation
transfer to the cloud and
processing without data management
pipelines BigTable bigquery data flow
and more our objective here is to solve
these common infrastructure problems for
the entire industry our cloud robotics
platform will be open-source and will be
built an open API will also provide the
interfaces needed for customers to port
their data to other platforms so there's
no vendor log in this cloud robotics
platform will be available to early
adopters at the beginning of next year
on top of this infrastructure we will
offer cloud services that leverage our
AI platform and solve several critical
customer pain points for the nation with
collaborative robots our slamed service
uses data from sensors like lighters or
depth cameras it allows robots to create
a map localize themselves relative to
that map and recognize static land parts
be further analyzed that sensor data to
discover walls doors shelves tables
chairs and other essential elements of
the robots workspace using that same
data we can also discover known objects
in their pose in the workspace this will
allow the robot to detect and plan
operations on these items where are we
going with this there's a prohibition
here our infrastructure enables reusable
assets on the robot and in the cloud it
can support not only the services I just
described but also serve as a foundation
for third party software our plan is to
work with our partners to grow this
platform into an ecosystem using an app
store for easy software distribution
ASAP as a developer in their customers
benefit from easier creation and
deployment of robotic automation
solutions they'll also be able to tap
into cloud-based analytics of sensor
data to expand their awareness of the
physical world with this platform when
abling developers to build innovative
reusable software and services for
whichever use cases or verticals they
want to tackle this will ultimately make
automation drastically simpler in
use the cause of custom integration
it'll also allow one of processes to be
automated seamlessly through the
orchestration of existing hardware and
software components collaborative robots
and more accessible automation will
complement local physical labor and
increase productivity where needed this
is how automation and AI can enhance
human skills right here in local labor
markets now please welcome Russian chef
director of product management who seen
this principle in action every day hi
everyone so you heard a lot about the
great technology that we have and what I
want to talk about a little bit more is
how customers are approaching this and
how you can think about approaching this
so what you've seen is that there is a
there's a spectrum of technologies as
Zhao has mentioned and really what this
what the what the trade-off here is the
flexibility that you have versus the
ease of use and so what we're really
trying to do is give you a variety of
options so that you can do many
different things and I want to explain
this a little bit and talk a little bit
about how our customers are using this
so on one hand you have our cloud TP use
which are very very very powerful and
many of our services are underlined by
calcloud TP use well we're now providing
access for people that that do have a
lot of machine learning expertise to be
able to utilize that to do some pretty
amazing things beyond that you have
tensor flow in cloud machine learning
engine where you can build your own
models beyond that you have cloud auto
ml which can do a variety of things to
be able to customize our models and then
you have our api's or building blocks
that you can prop bring together that
are Google's models where we're bringing
the best of Google's technology and all
of these let you actually really add
great value um and I think one thing
that's there is that we shouldn't mix
kind of ease-of-use versus versus value
there are a lot of things you can do by
just calling our API is that give you a
ton of value and we'll talk about that a
little bit so we'll start at the TPU end
a great use case for this is eBay and
this is something that they've recently
been doing which is they want to be able
to do visual product search and and and
do this across a variety of different
types of categories in many many
different different types of image
so they had a 55 million images in there
in their training product sudden they
have 1 billion product listings to
search for and so they use cloud TPS and
cloud TP use are very very good with
image recognition they increase their
image recognition accuracy by 10 percent
which is a huge difference for them and
makes a huge difference in their
business but then they also increase
their speed up time in training time by
a hundred X by using cloud TP use now if
you going with with tensorflow
there's a lot that you can do a
tensorflow it gives you a lot of
flexibility and a great example of this
is Okada Okada has done a variety of
things with our products but in one case
they were using this for fraud detection
and they built a tensor flow model for
for fraud detection they're the UK's
largest online grocer and there are lots
of transactions happening all of the
time and so they need to be able to
detect fraud so using tensor fold they
were able to get a 15 X increase in
fraud fraud detection precision and this
is just one of many things that they
could potentially do to help automate
their business now looking at auto ml I
think one of the biggest things with
Auto ml is that you can have customers
that don't have a lot of expertise in
machine learning do really really
powerful things and a great example of
this is bloom so bloom is an a European
manufacturer of European manufacturer of
furniture and they have hinges that are
all kinds of different types so they
were able to use auto ml to be able to
look at these hinges and classify these
hinges they have no in-house ml
expertise and they've never used GCP but
in five weeks they were able to create a
model with 91% accuracy then we talked a
little bit about the building blocks and
there this is a lot of where google has
brought kind of our best technologies to
bear and one of the most powerful ones
is translation and so I'd like to
welcome a adela quinones from Bloomberg
to talk to us about how they have been
using the translation API
[Applause]
so Adela can you tell us a little bit
more about Bloomberg and and what
Bloomberg does sure so Bloomberg is a
financial media and technology company
we're a news organization you might have
seen Bloomberg television or Bloomberg
radio and P a lot of people think of us
that way but at our core were really a
technology company we have 19,000
employees globally 5500 of which are
engineers so that's a quarter of our
company in engineering and we have a lot
of expertise in machine learning that we
really focus on something proprietary
problems Prime's aren't problems around
finance and data and so we're really
focused on on those use cases for from a
technology perspective makes sense and
what was the problem that you were
facing where you used our products and
then what and how are you solving it
before yeah so our newest product ingest
about two million stories a day we bring
in content that we produce ourselves
about 5,000 stories a day and also
content from premium providers like the
New York Times and The Washington Post
and also social media like Twitter so
it's a lot of content I'm coming through
our systems and for our clients
milliseconds matter you know a few
milliseconds can make the difference
between a great investment and a
not-so-great investment and so we wanted
to make that content available to our
clients in real time in the language
that that moat was most relevant to them
news is local it breaks in local
language and we wanted to be able to
make the content available in the in the
language that our clients understood so
I'll give you an example when the
municipal bond crisis was happening in
Puerto Rico there were reporters in the
courtroom taking notes and publishing
stories and tweets in Spanish not a lot
of our clients speak Spanish right so we
needed to be able to make that content
available to our customers in english or
their native language that makes sense
and because they were in puerto rico you
you could get increased the speed of
getting that content directly to your
clients exactly we wanted to really
narrow the time from when a piece of
news is available in any language and
it's available and we make it available
to the client in a language that they
can understand makes sense and so how
did Google Cloud help you solve this
yeah so um we
in 2015 we looked at kind of what you
know was available from a translation
perspective and we really wanted to
find a partner that could scale because
we have a lot of content that could
operate at great speed because you know
our own requirements are 100
milliseconds Ernests from the time the
news is published to the time we alert
our users about it and that could also
produce translations in lots of
different languages because we're seeing
growth all over the world and we want to
be able to support and kind of think
about our future and Google really
checked all the boxes on all three
fronts and I think another really nice
to have was the fact that it was so easy
to work with the Google team and to
connect to the Google API so from the
moment we decided we wanted to integrate
with Google to the moment when it was
available on our system I think it was
less than two weeks time so it was a
pretty remarkable turnaround make sense
and you touched on this a little bit but
why Google versus versus other
alternatives yeah I mean I think for one
the quality of Google Translate was
really high we integrated Google
Translate in 2015 before neural network
translation was introduced and at that
point we found that the quality in many
languages was very very good and in some
cases it was good enough for testing and
then when Google introduced neural
network translation that really changed
the game the quality was just really
really great and it allowed us actually
to expand our use of Google Translate
beyond just on-demand news translation
to other types of news translation it
makes sense
great we'll really really appreciate it
and it's a very great story all right
thank you thank you so part of what
we're really focusing on is not only
helping customers but also in that we've
been doing good with AI and so I'd like
to welcome up Pei Pei we our chief
scientists to talk to you about how
we're doing good with AI
good afternoon everyone
so the progress of AI has been
breathtaking at Google we are all in in
trying to build good AI technology and
products to deliver to all of you so
that it can make a positive impact I
want to close today's session by talking
about some of our shared
responsibilities of AI and how to make
it a benevolent technology you already
heard so much about our efforts in
different aspect of our technology
development our products and an across
the globe so it's not only just an
aspiration that we believe a technology
like this should bring benevolent impact
to our human society it's also something
we are putting action so I want to share
with you some of the actions we're
taking to start with let's just look at
an AI for a good example particularly
helping all of us to protect some of the
our most precious natural resources so
the World Wildlife Fund and the
Government of Nepal have built a network
of cameras to track endangered animals
like tigers and rhinos in the world but
they are really easy to miss these
animals don't come out so so fast so
they only come out sometimes a few
seconds so considering there are dozens
of cameras all rolling at once it's a
lot of work for humans to manually
monitor all of them and try to detect
and track and and spot these animals
that's where machine learning can help
I'm now going to show you two videos to
demonstrate how generic object tracking
and detection technology can help to
automate and assist this very difficult
and tedious process so this is you're
gonna see a tiger is
walking out of the fog and and then as
it comes closer to the camera a machine
learning generic object detection
algorithm will call out where the tiger
is so I feel this Tiger looks hungry
okay this one impressed me because the
first time I looked at it I didn't even
see the Rhino coming out of the bushes
again it's quite small and in a very
very cluttered environment but where our
generic object detection algorithm was
able to spot the Rhino even if part of
the body was being occluded and that's
going into different you know a
different mango and becoming smaller and
smaller so um it just warms my heart
that machine learning could do this for
our natural resources but to to really I
don't know how many of you were at
Diane's keynote yesterday she mentioned
that one of her friends was doing
wildlife preservation in in oceans and
today we are bringing professor Janet
ban unto the stage to share with us the
story of her work collaborating with
Google cloud AI on preserving wildlife
in ocean welcome professor
oh I need that thank you thank you it's
a delight to be here so you just heard
about identifying species using auto ml
I'm going to talk about identifying
individual animals tracking wildlife
with using ml so tracking individuals is
a critical part of violet of biology
because natural selection acts on the
variation between individuals it's also
important for conservation and
management and it also appeals to the to
the public in terms of their attraction
to individual animals and interest in
them a poignant and sad example that you
are probably all familiar with was the
Free Willy
also known as Keiko where people spent
over 20 million dollars on a lost cause
really to introduce him to the wild at
the same time the killer whales off the
coast of Washington State and British
Columbia have been declining and are on
the verge of extinction so you can use
the individual to engage people so this
was an example that wasn't very good but
it shows how important the individual is
in in understanding these animals so
there's lots of species that can be
tracked through time chimpanzees by
their faces zebras by stripes and
cheetah by the stripes on their tails
manta rays by the spots on their bellies
and whale sharks also by their spot
patterns and even toads by the gland
markings on the wyoming toad on their
backs so these are individually
distinctive but stable through time how
about individuals that change through
time so elephants feet are identified by
their ears and the tears changed through
time
sperm whales by the tail flukes and
actually most whale species by their
flukes and those patterns changed
through time and Rizzo dolphins by the
scarring and dorsal fins
so for over 30 years I've been studying
dolphins in Western Australia pretty far
remote place and we've been tracking
their residential population and we've
been tracking over 1,700 individuals
from birth to death they just lived
there this is bit fluke and as you can
see her fin has changed it is called
Shark Bay where I work and so the
dolphins do get bitten up by sharks and
their fins do change over time bit fluke
by the way ten years ago had a calf that
we named Google and Google is still
alive and well he's 10 years old
figuring out who his friends are and
then here's a zombie daughter of phantom
born in 2011 and as you can see zombies
been changed quite dramatically in four
years so we know these animals when we
can track them and basically how do you
track animals that you don't know so I'm
gonna take you to another part of the
world but first I want to say we gave
tens of thousands of photographs to the
Google Auto ml team to help us build
something that could track animals that
we know a lot less about so that was the
training data set and so taken to the
other side of the world the Potomac
Chesapeake yes there are dolphins in the
Potomac and because it is the Potomac
we've named them after presidents vice
presidents founding fathers first
families so this is Hubert Humphrey who
we seemed for three years in the Potomac
and to find out where these animals go
we because they're only there for about
six months of the year we want to see
where they winter and fortunately
scientists have been collecting dorsal
fin photographs from animals all over
the western Atlantic and so this is put
together in the mid-atlantic ball nose
dolphin catalog and so our challenge was
could we match the Potomac Chesapeake
dolphins to these other locations so I'm
going to show you an example using auto
ml and this way we could get a critical
problems in biology so this is George
Mason who was one of the key authors in
the Bill of Rights in case you're
interested but he was photographed in
the Potomac in 2015-2017 this is what it
looks like so we ran the image through
Auto ml and we tested it against the Mid
Atlantic bottlenose dolphin catalogue
and as you can see here the first two
that came up were actually George George
Mason and he was seen in off the coast
of North Carolina in 2008 and 2010 so
this is you know a ten year difference
practically and when this animal is seen
and this is how effective this has been
so Google Auto ml has enabled us to
identify individual dolphins in seconds
and to do this we've usually do our
matching by four animals that we know
but for animals that we don't know we
can use this technology to map them onto
animals in other locations and track
migrating individuals and this informs
us a lot about the populations for
conservation purposes so I want to thank
Google Auto Amalfi letting us helping us
with this and I'm gonna give the stage
back to pee thank you
that is just amazing
every time I it's not the first time I
saw it but I'm still just my hearts beat
my heart is beating we're looking at the
amazing result so we spent the past two
days sharing with you our excitement
about how a I can empower industries can
empower make life and work better when
it's applied right but the power does
demand responsibility and it is our
collective responsibility to make this a
benevolent technology earlier this year
that Google published AI principles to
guide our company's work and development
of AI to do the things that we believe
are important and adhere to our values
so today I'm gonna welcome on stage two
colleagues of mine who will share a
conversation with you with us about how
we can develop responsible AI both at
Google as well as inviting you to this
dialogue about why it's important to all
of us in the enterprise business and
about developing responsible AI
technology so please Tracy and Shannon
so um I'm gonna start with Shannon and
I'm going to read her bio word by word
because this is really impressive so
professor Shannon Veiler is a technology
ethicist and the mckennon professor of
philosophy at Santa Clara University
where she has taught since 2003 Shanna
has expertise in ethical implications of
AI and robotics she serves on the board
of directors of the non-profit
foundation for responsible robotics is a
member of the I Triple E global inched
initiative on AI and has received
multiple awards she's the author of 2016
book from Oxford University Press
technology and the virtuals a
philosophical guide to a future worth
wanting and I'm so excited to announce
now that Shannon has joined our Google
cloud team to work with us in terms of
developing responsible AI
so welcome Shanna Thank You Fifi and and
city next jenna is Tracy Frey I have to
say Tracy is one of my favorite
colleagues at Google I'm not just saying
this because we're on stage but you know
her her her energy her sense of moral
responsibility and her expertise in
understanding the problems and the
challenges and opportunities that AI can
bring to our customers is just
phenomenal and she is our cloud a eyes
go-to market strategist so we don't have
a whole lot of time but we're gonna have
a conversation here with you and hope to
open that conversation for many years to
come in this journey together about the
importance of this topic so I'm going to
start with Shannon why does ethics of AI
matter to any company including
enterprise companies
well I think you have to recognize that
a public trust is one of the most
important things that any corporation
needs to think about needs to earn and
public trust in technology is on a shaky
foundation these days and so lots of
companies are having to think about okay
well how do we cultivate and build up
that public trust in technology in a way
that's sincere and earned and I think
that one of the things that we have to
recognize is that we've been for a while
in a reactive mode where we see ethical
issues that crop up in society as a
result of the way certain technologies
are developed or deployed and then we
jump in and try to fix it but what we
really have to do is step back and start
getting into a more anticipatory mode
where we're seeing the road ahead a
little bit where we're thinking about
where the problems will crop up and we
do this and all other kinds of
engineering and technology development
with other kinds of issues right think
in a head about where you might have
some stress points or where you might
have some complications so now we just
have to bring the ethical expertise into
that process
great yeah so so turn a reactive
understanding to a proactive action of
embedding ethical and responsible
principles into the AI and technology so
to go a little more concrete because we
want to actually turn that into action
what are the key Ithaca principles for
an enterprise company who is practicing
AI well I think one of the things you
have to think about are what are gonna
be your stated goals and values and
right now I think especially given where
the public trust is right now and public
confidence I think fairness and
transparency have to be two of the
stated goals of any enterprise of any
organization that wants to earn the
public trust and then I think you also
have to think about values like safety
and security which sometimes we forget
that those are moral values right a
safety and security are about protecting
things that matter for people and so
thinking about those as values that were
committed to and that we have systems in
place to preserve is really important I
think we also have to recognize that the
other kinds of
that we might have in play in our
decisions even things we often think of
as just mechanical attributes like speed
or precision or efficiency that these
are values too and we have to have them
in the same conversation with the
decisions we're making about the ethical
values that were entrusted with
protecting because often there are some
very challenging trade-offs that happen
between values like speed and efficiency
and precision and other kinds of things
we care about like fairness transparency
and so on so I think understanding that
there are no ethically neutral decisions
that get made when you're talking about
technologies that shape people's lives
that influence the institutions in
society there's no way to be ethically
neutral or to detach yourself from that
set of questions so you have to just
dive in and try to get it right to
embrace it absolutely yeah so actually
Angela I'm speaking of practicing these
ethical AI principles so Tracy we we
rolled out AI principles earlier this
year and and we together and many of our
colleagues are working hard to make
responsibility a part of our process so
I would love for you to share with us a
share with our partners and enterprise
colleagues what we are doing yeah sure
and a lot of it is is a lot of what
Shannon was saying around starting at
the beginning and how do we think about
it from the earliest stages so within
cloud AI we've really taken the
responsible use of AI and made it a goal
of our development process so an
alongside the AI principles that I hope
everyone's had a chance to read if not
they're certainly easy to find on our on
our website but alongside those we
actually did our own sort of human
centered approach within kata I to say
what are the core values of this group
these are the set of humans who are
going to be creating this technology to
use at scale so what does this group
care about the most what do we think is
critical and that was what came out of
that was courage integrity compassion
and impact now given how rapidly this
market is expanding I mean just even the
size of this room or the size of this
conference the level of interest that we
see and how quickly it's being used
given that and the fact that many
customers really need to use their own
data as a part of any deployed solution
well that really makes the assessing of
fairness and ethical impact especially
at scale of AI technology in enterprises
it makes it really complex and so what
we've done is we we've really committed
to evaluating the work of cao dai
carefully and really in depth with the
goal of aligning it with those
principles from the time the development
starts all the way through to hearing
back from our customers and partners
when it's out in the world so can you
give us an example that a current cloud
AI product that has reflected this yeah
and certainly I think in in terms of
where it is in our product we're still
very at the very beginning of a lot of
this but even in auto ml for example we
worked really hard to create an
inclusive machine learning guide that's
available now to all of our customers
who are accessing auto ml and we worked
hard to build it into the product so as
you're building the model you can then
reference that guide and it's infused in
our documentation as well and then
eventually you know we're working hard
on on tools and testing of our own
models to transparency and all the kinds
of things that we can offer to you the
kinds of tools that we can build to give
to our customers around how they can
assess their own models and think about
what is in their data already and how to
think about it from an ethical
standpoint yeah one thing I think we all
share this experience a AI is a very
nascent technology but even with with
its Nason see the importance of fairness
and responsible development uses is
already very much important in our in
our products and on the mind of many
people so even that Google a lot of
these are the first steps
we're taking to make responsible a I
products so I wanna ask back to Shannon
that you talk about public trust public
trust is not something that Nash should
be a go it should be a consequence of
what we do that we earn that you you
said that so so you heard from Tracy
that Google is already starting to take
steps on that how do we sustain this how
do we sustain our AI principles and how
do we earn this long term especially
technology like a I and many others
changes rapidly yeah well and I think
that's the key is to understand that
this is a long game and not something
that has a quick easy technical fix or a
quick easy social fix and it's also
important to recognize that technologies
evolve people evolve with them
technology's also influenced other
technologies interact in surprising ways
sometimes with other technologies it's a
complex web that's constantly shifting
which means that to manage what's going
on in that web in a responsible way you
have to always be there and you have to
always be paying attention and you have
to be constantly seeing this as an
unending task something that you're not
looking to sort of finish and tie a bow
on turn your back on and walk away but
something that you're expecting that the
field of interaction between technology
and society and people is always going
to be shifting and managing that in a
trustworthy way is something that will
never stop being our responsibility yeah
that's that's great so um one last
question Shannon so you've been a
academia for most of your life and
working on books and theories and
philosophies of technology ethics but
now you're taking the step into the in
three world and putting all your
expertise and knowledge into practice
well what does that excite you what's
your yeah you know what what do you feel
about it or well I've always been more
of a practice oriented philosopher than
a theoretician it's partly why I came to
brown to study these topics I didn't
know philosophers or ho ho practice if
we do exist practice oriented
philosophers doing this maybe a little
fewer than they should be but we're out
there but you know I've been teaching
engineers and computer scientists for
over a decade
about these issues and teaching working
engineers even about how to develop
ethical principles and apply them in
different professional contexts most of
my research partners are people who are
involved in engineering and computer
science as well so it's an area that I'm
very comfortable in but in general I
also think that if philosophers are
available to step up when society needs
them then what good are we so I'm kind
of with Plato on that one those of you
who might have read Plato's Republic you
know there's this whole thing about when
society needs your help you have to put
the book down and and and step up and do
the work so I'm excited to be part of
Google's work now I can tell you we are
all excited to be working with you and
getting your advice along like you said
it's a it's a long term it's a long run
and it's a it's a journey we're gonna
share together so um our time is up and
I don't think there's any better way of
ending this session with the very quote
that Shanna has inspired me several
years ago when I was in the audience
listening to one of her talks is that
there's no independent machine values
machine values are human values and the
technology we create are eventually
going to be the technology that's going
to impact all of us our our communities
our families and our future generations
and we really want to invite you into
this journey to develop benevolent
irresponsible AI thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]